أريد منكم الرد على مزاعم
ارتكاب القوات السورية المدعومة من تركيا بارتكاب جرائم حرب ،
دعا نظيركم في أمريكا مارك ESPA تركيا إلى التحقيق في
مزاعم جرائم الحرب بما في ذلك
مزاعم القتل بإجراءات موجزة
والهجمات غير القانونية التي أدت إلى مقتل وإصابة
المدنيين.
سيتم
التحقيق في المزاعم بدقة ، هل هذا صحيح ،
هل تحقق في مزاعم
التعذيب هذه أولاً وقبل كل شيء ولكن قريبًا نعم
نعم بالطبع
من هذه القوات المدعومة من تركيا
وهل يمكنك القول بشكل قاطع أنه
ليس لديهم صلات بداعش والقاعدة
نعم  بالطبع ليس لدي أي
ارتباط بين نادية وبينهم
وبين المنظمات الإرهابية الأخرى
فهم في فكرتهم بالكامل على
الشعب السوري ومن ثم يقاتلون من
أجل استقلال الكرامة من أجل أرض الفكرة
تحت منازلهم.
اللعبة بقدر ما أفهمها
بالنسبة لتركيا في سوريا هي إعادة ثلاثة
ملايين ونصف المليون سوري  اللاجئين إلى
المنطقة الآمنة السيد.  يقترح أروين
بناء عشر مدن في تلك المنطقة الآمنة
باستخدام الأموال الدولية لتغطية
تكلفة حوالي ستة وعشرين مليار دولار. من
أين ستأتي هذه الأموال هل
من الواضح أننا بحاجة إلى منطقة نادية الآمنة
في شمال سوريا لإعادة
اللاجئين ومعظمهم في تركيا  من
مكان آخر عندما يكون المنزل
بيوتنا وكرامتنا تقرض طواعية
وآمنة والقرار ما
نحاول القيام به رقم واحد ثم في
نفس الوقت أعني فكرة بالطبع عند
الرحلة بنيت في النهاية منازل جديدة
لبناء لك  تعرف على دعمهم
للمساعدة المعدنية بالطبع لم نقم ببعض
التقارير المالية للدعم